drive in Paris and you'll probably end
up driving a French car this is a nation
that prides itself on its motor industry
on the global reach of its French
products but here at the country's
motoring showcase there is nervousness
about the specter of Britain leaving the
European Union without a deal on this
sprawling stand we find the cars of PSA
france's biggest manufacturer the owner
of Citroen Peugeot and also the British
brand voxel if we tariff barriers coming
it will clearly have an impact on the
business
and today's has a lots of question about
it no answer but we really are urging
the UK government and the European
Commission to find a clear a final point
to that with a transparent and clear
solution this is applied component
technology in Wrexham they make parts
here for voxel and that's why the
decisions being discussed in Paris
reverberate across the UK among these
manufacturers there is a genuine fear
that a No Deal brexit would lead to
import tariffs and to a weaker pound and
that that would wipe out the profits
they make on cars they sell in Britain
their response I'm told will be one or
two things either they stop selling cars
in Britain that's unlikely or else on
mass all these companies just work up
the prices they charge us we will be
adjusting our pricing to reflect the
economic situation and I hope that the
British drivers will still be able to
enjoy the obvious products but all I can
tell you is our prices will fluctuate
according to what the economy condition
will be after the break seats this is an
industry often accused of scare
mongering so I put that accusation to
the man whose job is to represent
Europe's car makers currently we don't
see a deal in front of us so as long
there is no deal we are indeed concerned
about what the implications will be and
the implications could be tough
not only for the manufacturers but also
for the employee
the jobs we are creating beat in UK as
well as in Europe so we should be
concerned because we should take care of
these jobs driving in Paris can see made
the wildering mass of cars confusion and
brinksmanship for some in the auto
industry that's how brexit feels right
now Adam Parsons Sky News Paris